SARAH SANDERS, ARI FLEISCHER,
DONALD TRUMP JR.,
GOVERNOR MIKE HUCKABEE, SO MANY
OTHERS.
FIRST TONIGHT WITH JUST 27 DAYS
UNTIL ELECTION DAY, YOU WERE THE
ULTIMATE JURY.
SOMETHING PRETTY REMARKABLE
HAPPENED.
FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME SINCE
BEING TAPPED BY JOE BIDEN TO
SERVICE HIS RUNNING MATE,
KAMALA HARRIS TONIGHT WAS FORCED
TO ANSWER SERIOUS QUESTIONS
ABOUT HER TRACK RECORD, HER PAST
COMMENTS, AND YES, HER
FRIGHTENING SOCIALIST AGENDA.
AND THANKS TO THE CORRUPT MEDIA
MOB, WHICH IS ALL IN ON TEAM
BIDEN, SENATOR HARRIS HAS NEVER
BEEN ASKED TO SERIOUSLY ADDRESS
ANY CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE.
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE, THE TIME THAT
SENATOR HARRIS SAID THAT SHE
BELIEVED THE SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST JOE BIDEN OR
THE TIME THAT SHE ACCUSED
JOE BIDEN OF CODDLING THE
REPUTATION OF SEGREGATIONISTS
COME OF THOSE STILL NEED TO BE
ASKED.
OR THE TIME THAT SHE ALL BUT
CALLED JOE BIDEN A RACIST ON A
PRIMARY DEBATE STAGE AND SAID
SHE WOULDN’T BE A SENATOR IF THE
PEOPLE HE PRAISED HAD HAD THEIR
WAY.
OR THE TIME THAT IN FACT IT CAME
UP OFTEN SHE COSPONSORED THE
RADICAL GREEN NEW DEAL IN THE
SENATE OR THE TIME SHE WANTED TO
BAN RED MEAT, PLASTIC STRAWS,
BAN OIL, GAS, AND YES, SHE SAID
IT, JOE HAS SAID IT MANY TIMES,
WE WILL PROVE IT IN A MINUTE,
FRACKING.
OR THE TIME, BY THE WAY, SHE
CALLED FOR GUN CONFISCATION VIA
EXECUTIVE ORDER IF CONGRESS
DIDN’T ACT THE WAY SHE WANTED.
AND LET’S NOT FORGET THE TIME
THAT SHE PUBLICLY SUPPORTED
COURT PACKING.
BY THE WAY, SHE AGAIN TONIGHT
REFUSED TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S GOING TO GO
OVER WELL.
FOR THE TIME THAT SHE SMEARED
JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
THAT WAS BROUGHT UP TONIGHT AND
TRIED TO RUIN HIS LIFE, OR THE
TIME THAT SHE SUPPORTED MEDICARE
FOR ALL OR THE TIME THAT SHE
SUPPORTED TAXPAYER-FUNDED
HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS OR THE TIME THAT SHE
COMPARED LAW ENFORCEMENT TO THE
KU KLUX KLAN.
IN OTHER WORDS, I.C.E. AGENTS,
OR THE TIME THAT SHE SUPPORTED A
BAIL FUND THAT GOT WRITERS AND
EVEN ACCUSED CHILD RAPISTS OUT
OF JAIL LIKE SHE DID IN
MINNESOTA OR THE TIME SHE PLACED
MY PRAISED LOS ANGELES FOR
SLASHING THE POLICE BUDGET, IN
OTHER WORDS, DEFUNDING THE
POLICE.
SENATOR HARRIS HAS NEVER BEEN
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR ANY OF THIS
AND WITH JUST 27 DAYS TO GO, WE
GOT OUR FIRST INSIGHT INTO ALL
THESE QUESTIONS SHE HAS NEVER
ANSWERED.
THAT WAS UNTIL VICE PRESIDENT
MIKE PENCE, HE TOOK MATTERS INTO
HIS OWN HANDS AND THE
VICE PRESIDENT STARTED BY
HOLDING THE BIDEN-HARRIS
CAMPAIGN RESPONSIBLE FOR
PLAGIARIZING WHAT WAS THE
PRESIDENT’S PLAN IN RESPONSE TO
COVID-19.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE REALITY IS WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE BIDEN PLAN, IT READS AN
AWFUL LOT LIKE THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I AND THE
TASK FORCE HAVE BEEN DOING EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY.
AND QUITE FRANKLY, WHEN I LOOK
AT THEIR PLAN THAT TALKS ABOUT
ADVANCING TESTING, CREATING NEW
PPE, DEVELOPING A VACCINE, IT
LOOKS A LITTLE BIT LIKE
PLAGIARISM, WHICH IS SOMETHING
JOE BIDEN KNOWS A LITTLE
SOMETHING ABOUT.
>> Sean: AS YOU CAN SEE, IT
WAS PRETTY OBVIOUS AUTHOR OF THE
EVENING, FOR THE ENTIRE
90 MINUTES SENATOR HARRIS WAS
VERY UNCOMFORTABLE WHEN
CONFRONTED WITH THE TRUTH.
AT TIMES SHE COULD DO LITTLE
MORE THAN MAKE THESE AWKWARD
SMILES AND JUST SHAKE HER HEAD
AND CLEARLY SHE BLATANTLY LIED
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
LET’S START WITH OUR LIVE
TONIGHT ABOUT TAXES.
WATCH THIS.
>> HE SAYS HE’S SMART BECAUSE HE
CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE TAX
CODE, AND HE DOES TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE TAX CODE.
THAT’S WHY I’M GOING TO A
LIMITED TO TRUMP TAX CUTS.
I’M GOING TO ILLUMINATE THOSE.
>> THE TRUTH AND THE FACT IS
JOE BIDEN AS BEEN VERY CLEAR, HE
WILL NOT RAISE TAXES ON ANYBODY
WHO MAKES LESS THAN $400,000 A
YEAR.
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, AND
SPEAKING.
I’M SPEAKING.
>> THE IMPORTANT ISSUE IS THE
TRUTH.
JOE BIDEN SAID TWICE IN THE
DEBATE LAST WEEK THAT HE’S GOING
TO REPEAL THE TRUMP TAX CUTS.
THAT WAS TAX CUTS THAT GAVE THE
AVERAGE WORKING FAMILY $2,000 IN
A TAX BREAK --
>> THAT IS ABSOLUTELY --
>> Sean: I GUESS THE MEDIA MOB
WILL TRY AND PROTECT BOTH
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS, BUT
SHE WAS CAUGHT OUTRIGHT LYING TO
HER TEETH ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
FRACKING AND WE’VE GOT ALL THE
VIDEO EVIDENCE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I AM NOT BANNING FRACKING.
LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN.
I AM NOT BANNING FRACKING.
>> NO NEW FRACKING.
>> WOULD THERE BE ANY PLACE FOR
FOSSIL FUELS INCLUDING COAL AND
FRACKING IN A BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CAME AT >> NO, WE
WOULD WORK IT OUT, WE WOULD MAKE
SURE IT’S ELIMINATED AND NO MORE
SUBSIDIES FOR EITHER ONE OF
THOSE.
>> SO FIRST OF ALL, I WILL
REPEAT AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
KNOW THAT JOE BIDEN WILL NOT BAN
FRACKING.
THAT IS A FACT.
>> WILL YOU COMMIT TO
IMPLEMENTING A FEDERAL BAN ON
FRACKING YOUR FIRST DAY IN
OFFICE?
, ADDING THE UNITED STATES
TO THE LIST OF COUNTRIES WHO --
>> THERE’S NO QUESTION I’M IN
FAVOR OF BANNING FRACKING.
>> Sean: I’M IN FAVOR OF
BANNING FRACKING, JOE BIDEN, I
WILL ELIMINATE FRACKING.
THEY SAID IT, NOW BOTH JOE BIDEN
AND KAMALA HARRIS DENYING THEIR
OWN WORDS.
AND BY THE WAY, FOLLOWING THOSE
REMARKS, OCASIO-CORTEZ, WELL,
SHE SENT A VERY STERN REMINDER
TO KAMALA HARRIS ON TWITTER
WRITING FRACKING IS BAD,
ACTUALLY.
AND MEANWHILE, WHEN
SENATOR HARRIS WAS FINALLY
FORCED TO ANSWER FOR BIDEN TO
FOSTER THIS RELATIONSHIP WITH
CHINA, HARRIS TRIED TO JOT DOWN
MY DODGE THAT QUESTION, TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS.
>> JOE I THINK HE SAID IT QUITE
WELL, HE SAID FOREIGN POLICY
MIGHT SOUND COMPLICATED BUT
REALLY IT’S RELATIONSHIPS.
JUST THINK ABOUT IT IS
RELATIONSHIPS.
SO WE KNOW THIS IN OUR PERSONAL
AND PROFESSIONAL RELATIONSHIPS.
YOU’VE GOT TO KEEP YOUR WORD TO
YOUR FRIENDS.
GOT TO BE LOYAL TO YOUR FRIENDS,
PEOPLE WHO STOOD WITH YOU, GOT
TO STAND WITH THEM.
YOU’VE GOT TO KNOW WHO YOUR
ADVERSARIES ARE AND KEEP THEM IN
CHECK.
>> Sean: THE VICE PRESIDENT
WAS NICER THAN I WOULD HAVE BEEN
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT JOE IS
LOYAL TO HIS FRIENDS.
YOU KNOW, LIKE THE PEOPLE IN
UKRAINE WHERE ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER MADE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OR CHINA WHERE ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER GOT A $1.5 BILLION DEAL
WITH THE BANK OF CHINA.
I GUESS THAT’S LOYAL TO YOUR
FRIENDS.
WHY ON EARTH WOULD
SENATOR HARRIS OR JOE BIDEN EVER
HAVE ANYTHING NEGATIVE TO SAY
ABOUT CHINA?
AFTER ALL, JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN
SUCKING UP TO CHINA FOR DECADES
AND THAT’S LIKELY THE REASON
ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER HAS BEEN
LINING HIS POCKETS WITH
SWEETHEART DEALS CONNECTED TO
THE COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA FOR
YEARS.
AND SHOPPING SPREES THANKS TO
CHINA NATIONALS, CHINESE
NATIONALS, OR UKRAINIAN
OLIGARCHS OR RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS,
AS WE’VE ONLY RECENTLY LEARNED.
AND ACCORDING TO THAT U.S.
SENATE REPORT THAT WAS PUT OUT
BY CHARLES GRASSLEY AND
SENATOR JOHNSON, HUNTER BIDEN
ACTUALLY OPENED A JOINT BANK
ACCOUNT WITH A CHINESE NATIONAL,
GUESS WHY?
TO FUND $100,000 SHOPPING SPREE
FOR MEMBERS OF HUNTER’S FAMILY.
ALSO REPORTEDLY SCORED LUCRATIVE
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR BUSINESS
DEALS WITH FOREIGN NATIONALS
ASSOCIATED WITH CHINA’S
COMMUNIST PARTY AND ALSO CHINA’S
MILITARY AND DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS WERE OPENLY WORRIED
THAT HUNTER ’HAS PROBLEMATIC
ACTIVITIES AND BUSINESS DEALINGS
CREATE SERIOUS
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE AND
EXTORTION CONCERNS.
MAYBE, I DON’T KNOW, I’M JUST
GUESSING, THAT’S WHY FOR THE
FIRST PART OF -- LET’S SEE,
THROUGH JANUARY, THE END OF
JANUARY AND THE PRESIDENT PUT
THE TRAVEL BAN IN EFFECT TEN
DAYS AFTER THE FIRST IDENTIFIED
CASE OF CORONA IN AMERICA,
JOE BIDEN CALLED IT XENOPHOBIC
AND HYSTERICAL AND ALSO
FEARMONGERING.
WHY?
MAYBE HE WANTED MORE DEALS FOR
HUNTER, TONIGHT, BY FAR THE MOST
CRINGEWORTHY DISTURBING MOMENT
OF THE DEBATE CAME WHEN
KAMALA HARRIS DID EVERYTHING SHE
COULD DO NOT TO ANSWER WHETHER
OR NOT SHE OR JOE BIDEN SUPPORT
PACKING THE U.S. SUPREME COURT.
SOMETHING THAT HASN’T HAPPENED
IN OVER 150 YEARS.
WITH ALWAYS HAD NONMEMBERS ON
THE COURT.
WELL, APPARENTLY THERE’S A
REASON THEY WON’T ANSWER.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> THANK YOU, SENATOR HARRIS.
>> PEOPLE ARE VOTING RIGHT NOW,
THEY WOULD LIKE TO KNOW IF YOU
AND JOE BIDEN ARE GOING TO PACK
THE SUPREME COURT IF YOU DON’T
GET YOUR WAY IN THIS NOMINATION.
>> LET’S TALK ABOUT PACKING.
>> A NONANSWER, JOE BIDEN GIVEN
ON NONANSWER --
>> I’M TRYING TO ANSWER YOU NOW.
>> IF YOU HAVEN’T FIGURED IT OUT
YET, THE STRAIGHT ANSWER IS THEY
ARE GOING TO PACK THE
SUPREME COURT IF THEY SOMEHOW
WIN THE SELECTION.
>> Sean: THIS IS BEYOND A
SERIOUS TOPIC.
WHY?
BECAUSE WE HAVE COEQUAL BRANCHES
OF GOVERNMENT, WE HAVE CHECKS
AND BALANCES AND WHETHER OR NOT
ALL THREE COEQUAL BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT WILL SURVIVE A
POTENTIAL BIDEN-HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION.
IN SENATOR HARRIS THINKS THAT
SHE CAN JUST POND?
WELL, THAT’S PRETTY
UNCONSCIONABLE.
WHAT WOULD THAT MEAN?
THAT WOULD MEAN RADICAL JUSTICES
ON THE U.S. SUPREME COURT IN,
WHAT, PERPETUITY.
THEY’RE GOING TO PUT 11 ON THE
COURT, 13 ON THE COURT, HOW
ABOUT GO FOR A NICE EVENING 18?
THAT WOULD BE PRETTY REPULSIVE
BECAUSE WHAT PEOPLE CAN’T GET
DONE LEGISLATIVELY OR CAN’T GET
DONE AT THE BALLAST SUMMIT
BALLOT BOX BY CONVINCING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THEY WOULD HELP
ACTIVIST JUSTICES WOULD DO FOR
THE SUPREME COURT.
GIVING HER DODGY REMARKS, YOU
BETTER BELIEVE THAT IS CERTAINLY
ON THE TABLE.
BY THE WAY, JUST LIKE GETTING
RID OF THE LEGISLATIVE
FILIBUSTER AND PUSHING FOR
STATEHOOD FOR PUERTO RICO AND
D.C. IF THEY GET ELECTED.
MORE QUESTIONS THEY NEED TO
ANSWER BECAUSE IF ELECTED, THAT
WOULD MEAN A DEMOCRATIC MAJORITY
IN THE U.S. SENATE PROBABLY IN
PERPETUITY.
THAT MEANS THIS SHOULD BE THE
MOST RADICAL AND DESTRUCTIVE
ADMINISTRATION IN AMERICAN
HISTORY AND THEY DON’T WANT THE
27 DAYS OUTSIDE OF AN ELECTION
BE HONEST AND FORTHRIGHT AND
TRANSPARENT WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IF YOU DO CARE ABOUT
CONSTITUTIONAL ORDER, IF YOU
CARE ABOUT COEQUAL BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT, IF YOU CARE ABOUT
CHECKS AND BALANCES, IF YOU CARE
ABOUT SOMETHING CALLED THE
BILL OF RIGHTS, YOUR FREEDOMS,
YOUR PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS, WELL,